le samu est en première ligne dans la
lutte contre le coc vite 19 mai depuis
sa création le 15 subi de nombreux abus
le 15
un numéro unique pour toute la france
depuis 1986 il est censé apporter plus
d'efficacité et de simplicité mais une
confusion peigne dans l'esprit des
français
même cinq ans après sa création le
public ne fait pas encore bien la
différence entre ce 15 le 16 ou le 18 il
arrive encore beaucoup d'appels bidon et
c'est là qu'intervient l'expérience du
permanenciers quoi que penser des fois
ça énerve quand on en a beaucoup de la
journée mais si on en a pas beaucoup
pour moi ces tournois confusion et
canular met en péril l'activité des
secours l'exemple dans ce centre de la
loire en 1996 500 décalage
méconnaissance des services du centre 15
panique incontrôlée des familles il y a
des jours où le standard saturent le
dernier dimanche de pâques 1426 appel en
tout genre sont arrivés ici 1426 appel
pour vingt-et-une intervention c'est à
peine plus qu'un week end ordinaire
ça craint un encombrement et ferris
effectivement de retarder l'intervention
grande au détriment d'intervention qui
ne sont pas graves depuis les années 80
le samu organise des campagnes
d'information
et même après plus de 20 ans d'existence
la leçon ne semble pas assimilé à priori
de votre enfant qu'il y en a plein il
décroche de téléphone le samu de paris
les urgences sur dix appels vous pouvez
avoir neuf erreurs ou fax il 10ème appel
peut-être l'arrêt cardiaque qui attend
derrière
aujourd'hui la préoccupation du salut
c'est la banalisation des appels non
urgents
moi qui suis là depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années j'ai vu une évolution
au départ le samu a été appelé que pour
les urgences vitales au casino pour les
orientales et au fil des années on a vu
des choses qui concernaient plutôt de la
médecine générale d'une problème suivre
dalmau des problèmes dentaires et
effectivement c'est une évolution le
dire qu'on qui se continue plus que
jamais en cette pandémie de covin 19 le
samu en appelle à la responsabilité des
français
[Musique]